(gentle music)
- Hi Lucy, good morning.
It's me, Henry.
We are on, I think about
our 5,000th date together.
It's been great.
I'm gonna catch you up.
(gentle music)
You have a thing called
amnesia and I am your husband.
We have a daughter and she's about 40 now,
or something like that.
- Wait, what?
I know it's bananas, but I'm not done yet.
It's 2020 and we're also in
the middle of a pandemic,
which is a terrible thing.
Baseball games are now being played
in front of cardboard people.
(crickets chirping)
- Sounds kind of like
you're making this up.
- Oh yes.
If the room you're in right
now smells a bit like farts,
that was you.
- It does kind of smell
like farts in here.
Are you sure that wasn't you?
- Oh, it doesn't matter, either way.
There is good stuff going
on in the world though.
There's a company called Netflix
that provides premium
entertainment to people
right in the comfort of their own home.
They also pay me,
so that's why we can
have that house together.
So to recap, 2020 is not
great, Netflix is good,
and you fart a lot in your sleep.
Drew, in all seriousness though,
I want to just tell you this.
I couldn't honestly be
more excited for you.
You have your own show now.
- Hi, I'm Tom.
Lucy's got her own show now?
- Tom!
- Yes, yes.
10 Second Tom, that's right.
- That's great!
Who's Lucy?
And why is everyone
outside wearing a mask?
- Okay, Tom, that's
enough, you gotta go now.
- Okay.
- You are gonna make
people so happy every day,
every time they see you.
You are magic.
The whole world feels it,
and I'm lucky that I know you so well.
I love you.
- I can't think of any endeavor
I'd ever want to do without you, Adam.
So thanks, and I love you.
- Hi, I'm Tom!